[Música]
el Secretario de Defensa de Estados
Unidos hoy Ostin aseguró que buscarán
hasta debajo de las piedras al
responsable de la reciente filtración de
documentos del pentágono el funcionario
añadió que Washington continúa
trabajando de cerca con sus socios Pese
a que los archivos presuntamente revelan
que la administración vaivén habría
espiado a países aliados
Colombia Panamá y Estados Unidos
acordaron una campaña de dos meses de
duración para enfrentar la migración
irregular a través del llamado tapón del
Darién la selva que ocupa la zona
fronteriza entre Colombia y Panamá la
iniciativa Busca acabar con el tránsito
ilícito de personas y de bienes
en Chile el presidente Gabriel boriche
celebró la decisión Del parlamento que
aprobó reducir la jornada laboral de 45
a 40 horas el jefe de estado de la
calificó de indispensable para un chile
más justo la normativa se implementará
gradualmente hasta llegar a la meta en
cinco años
Bienvenidos a esta informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos comenzamos en
Estados Unidos donde el gobierno
continúa tratando de aplacar las
consecuencias de la filtración de
documentos del pentágono que
presuntamente revelan que la
administración vaiden habría espiado a
socios o como Ucrania Israel o Egipto el
Secretario de Defensa al oído Austin
aseguró que buscarán hasta debajo de las
piedras para identificar al responsable
ampliamos los detalles en el informe
un escándalo de filtración de documentos
secretos principalmente sobre la guerra
en Ucrania que había pasado
desapercibida hasta la revelación del
periódico estadounidense de New York
Times el 7 de abril ahora la filtración
sacude a más aliados de Estados Unidos y
ha obligado a que el departamento de
Justicia inicie una investigación y que
el Secretario de Defensa se pronuncie
me informaron por primera vez sobre los
informes de divulgación no autori de
material confidencial y clasificado en
la mañana del 6 de abril hemos remitido
el asunto al departamento de Justicia
que ha abierto una investigación penal
les diré que nos tomamos esto muy en
serio y continuaremos investigando y
removiendo cada piedra hasta que
encontremos la fuente de esto y su
alcance
decenas de fotos de los documentos
algunos marcados como Ultra secretos han
estado circulando en redes sociales y
servicios de mensajería como discord
Twitter y Telegram antes de ser
descubiertos por el gobierno
estadounidense los documentos incluyen
evaluaciones del pentágono según las
cuales Ucrania podría quedarse sin
municiones en cuestión de semanas estos
documentos también revelan información
sobre otros aliados como Israel Turquía
Australia y Corea del Sur algunos
sugiriendo que Estados Unidos estaba
espiando las conversaciones internas en
seúl dado que Corea del Sur y Estados
Unidos son aliados en materia de
inteligencia ahora llevamos a cabo
juntos actividades de inteligencia sobre
cuestiones importantes se espera que
este incidente sirva para que ambas
partes sigan reforzando la confianza
mutua pero los expertos en inteligencia
afirman que espiar a otros países
incluidos los aliados es una práctica
bastante habitual en la política
internacional y nada que esos países no
sepan ya el pentágono afirma que ha
tomado medidas para reducir el número de
personas que tienen acceso al material
clasificado
reunidos en Ciudad de Panamá el
secretario de seguridad Nacional de
Estados Unidos y los cancilleres de
Panamá y Colombia acordaron un plan de
dos meses para enfrentar la migración
irregular en la selva del Darién que
conecta a Panamá y a Colombia la campaña
Busca acabar con el movimiento ilícito
de personas y de bienes por vía
terrestre o marítima en una de las
regiones más afectadas por los flujos
migratorios irregulares con más de
87,000 cruces solo en lo que va de 2023
y el plan llega cuando falta sólo un mes
para el momento en que se prevé expire
en Estados Unidos el título 42 que
permite expulsar a migrantes en la
frontera por temas sanitarios
Panamá Colombia Panamá Colombia y
Estados Unidos se enfocarán en tres
líneas de esfuerzo terminar con el
movimiento ilícito de bienes y personas
a través del Darién y el corredor
marítimo que lleva a la muerte y
explotación de personas vulnerables por
ganancias significativas abrir nuevos
caminos legales para decenas de miles de
migrantes y refugiados como una
alternativa a la migración irregular y
tercero lanzar un plan para reducir la
pobreza y crear empleos en comunidades
fronterizas del norte de Colombia y sur
de Panamá para asociarse con organismos
internacionales instituciones
financieras y el sector privado
las autoridades de Guatemala recibieron
los cuerpos de los 17 nacionales que
fallecieron en medio del incendio dentro
de un centro de detención de migrantes
de Ciudad Juárez en México el pasado 27
de marzo con un minuto de silencio
inicio el homenaje a las víctimas que
llegaron en un avión de la Fuerza Aérea
Mexicana guate temala hace parte del
proceso penal en México contra los
presuntos responsables de la
conflagración que dejó 40 fallecidos
al menos nueve personas perdieron la
vida en medio de un tiroteo registrado
en el norte de Ecuador los hechos
ocurrieron en un puerto pesquero de
esmeraldas capital de la provincia
ecuatoriana del mismo nombre fronteriza
con Colombia cuando un grupo armado
abrió Fuego contra Pescadores que
trabajaban en la zona Gustavo Ortega
corresponsal de France 24 en Quito nos
amplió los detalles un ataque de 20
personas fuertemente armadas al estilo
sicariato se produjo en el puerto
pesquero artesanal y la provincia
costera de esmeraldas según el informe
policial la lucha de territorio y
enfrentamientos entre grupos
delincuencia organizada son los motivos
de los ataques producidos en Ecuador
recientemente en medio de una gran
crisis de inseguridad que vive el país
el ataque se produjo con armas cortas y
armas largas según informó el titular de
interior y Justicia ecuatoriano Juan
Zapata quien confirmó que en el lugar
existe más de 200 indicios balísticos
registrados en el lugar del suceso la
Policía Nacional y las fuerzas armadas
desarrollan operativo y se han
confirmado 60 allanamientos hasta el
momento para capturar hacia los
responsables sucedió cuando los
atacantes llega formar y por tierra y
dispararon indiscriminadamente cuando se
encontraban dos mil personas en el
sector entre pesqueros y comerciantes
según informaron las autoridades el
ministro de interior y Justicia confirmó
que los ataques son consecuencias de
operativos en contra el narcotráfico y
el crimen organizado que intenta cambiar
a la modalidad de las vacunas a
comerciantes la provincia de esmeraldas
se mantuvo en un estado de sección desde
el 3 de marzo hasta el 10 de Abril donde
se decomisaron solo en esta provincia
1403 kilogramos de droga y se
desarticularon a cinco grupos
organizados los trabajadores que se
encontraban en el lugar se lanzaron al
mar para intentar sobrevivir al ataque
armado la provincia de esmeraldas maneja
la tasa de muertes más violentas del
país con un promedio de 16 asesinatos
por día pasamos a Chile la cámara de
diputados aprobó una ley que reduce de
45 a 40 las horas laborales por semana
un proyecto que había sido presentado
inicialmente en 2017 pero que enfrentó
muchas complicaciones hasta que fue fue
tomado por el presidente Gabriel borich
el año pasado la normativa ahora espera
la promulgación del mandatario y
convertirla paulatina y convertiría
paulatinamente al país durante los
próximos cinco años en una de las pocas
excepciones en la región donde la
mayoría de semanas de trabajo son de 48
horas queremos manifestar una gran
alegría porque hoy día ha quedado
demostrado que aunque algunos pensaran
que era imposible avanzar en una mejor
calidad de vida para las y los
trabajadores de nuestro país sí se puede
cerramos en Cuba donde el gobierno
autorizó los depósitos en dólares algo
que se había prohibido desde 2021 ahora
El Ejecutivo publicó una ley que
revierte esa medida argumentando que es
el camino más aconsejable por la
situación económica de la isla pero
entre la población la opinión se divide
Marta Moya nos explica
revertir medidas para paliar la crisis
económica en la noche del lunes el
diario oficial de Cuba publicó una
resolución por la que se da luz verde a
los depósitos en dólares estadounidenses
en el sistema bancario local dando
marcha atrás a su propia prohibición
promulgada en 2021 cuando el gobierno
argumentó que el bloqueo de Estados
Unidos imposibilitaba que Cuba sacara
dinero al exterior en dólares la
bancarización del dólar es una medida
motivada por actuales condiciones del
país que beneficiará la actividad
económica nacional y a la población a
pesar de la vigencia de las medidas de
Estados Unidos que obstaculizan los
flujos financieros de Cuba e impiden
depósitos en el exterior de dólares en
efectivo el Banco Central confirmó que
dada la situación económica de La Isla
la medida Era la más aconsejable todo
ello mientras la nación caribeña
recupera paulatinamente el turismo tras
los impactos de la pandemia de covid-19
entre la población las opiniones están
divididas en torno a esta medida eso es
algo positivo que realmente se debería
haber hecho hace mucho tiempo no
lo que ayuda a la economía realmente en
todo en todo sentido yo apuesto por el
cup es nuestra moneda es la que hay que
fortalecer Y esa es la que nos va a
nosotros llevar a salir de todos los
problemas que tenemos hoy
cuando tengamos que usar todas las otras
monedas internacionalmente para hacer
transacciones para comprar y todo eso
pero yo la he puesto en mi Cuba al cvp
una inflación del 39% en 2022 en la isla
exacerbó la escasez de Divisas
medicamentos alimentos y combustibles
mientras la limitación de dólares creó
un mercado ilegal de facto que ahora se
podría regularizar
fin del informativo gracias por su
sintonía
[Música]